uh with westminster roiling widespread
anger up and down the country it's also
a critical moment for the labour party
having bided its time in recent months
the leadership has now called for boris
johnson to resign and the party's taken
a commanding lead in the polls
consistently ten or more points ahead of
the conservatives so with an election
potentially less than two years away is
labour ready for government i'm joined
now by the shadow health secretary
wes streeting now we're streeting if
your leader gets his way you'd be health
secretary sooner rather than later so um
could we just dispense with the bit
where i say
you know
ask you about something and then you
tell me what's wrong with the
government's actions and go straight to
the part where i asked you this given
all the signs are that on the omicron
wave though not gone is less dangerous
than it was would you be inclined if you
were health secretary to relax the
current restrictions at the next review
on january 26th well we'll follow the
data closely we hope so in that we don't
want any more restrictions or measures
than are absolutely necessary i think
the cautionary note we've got to bear in
mind is that london might be over the
peak of the wave the rest of england is
still bearing the brunt of it and for
lots of reasons particularly population
size
capacity and resilience london's nhs
system is in a stronger position than
other parts of the nhs so we can't be
complacent about that what i have done
today
though is send a very strong message to
the country about the need to live well
with covert and we've heard
lots of conservative mps talk about
living with covid and my anxiety about
that has been two fronts there are some
conservative backbenchers who for whom
living with covid means
ending all measures including the
testing regime and everything else
that's reckless and irresponsible you've
got the health secretary says we need to
live with covid but doesn't seem to have
a plan so we set out 10 points that we
think the government should
introduce in order to live well with
covert in longer term some are things
they should do immediately some are
longer longer-term objectives but the
goal here is to make sure that we never
have to go into lockdown again and that
we can move forward as a country
protecting public health but doing so in
a way that protects lives livelihoods
and liberties so in fact you are already
preparing for as it were to shift from a
pandemic to endemic yes and i think
that's the sensible thing to do and and
you're right say at the outset we can't
be complacent we're following the data i
was reassured actually by what oliver
dowden said about following the data
because i'll be honest my anxiety
reading the sunday papers this morning
was that this stuff about ending plan b
measures was driven more by the politics
of the situation uh you know boris
johnson's personal political problems
needing to throw some red meat to back
benches who might be writing the letters
in and trying to say oh let's move on
from the downing street parties onto
onto plan b measures and grab some
headlines so um i i want the government
to be motivated by public health and as
you remember from when i came on before
christmas one of the reasons why we
signaled labour support for plan b
measures well in advance of the vote was
to give the health secretary the
confidence to know he had the votes so
my message to him this morning
we've got regardless of all the noise
about boris johnson
and the mess he's caused for his own
party and government let's keep public
health at the forefront of our minds and
let's plan on that basis well it's
rather um difficult to avoid the mess uh
that
as you described it that uh miss
johnson's cause if you want to put it
that way and just in passing i apologize
to viewers if
i brought something personal into into
this discussion let's try and uh keep
above that um now your parties obviously
benefited from the revelations uh that
have been coming out day off today
but let's just clear up one thing
because it came up yesterday um your own
leaders not averse to a quick snifter
during the working days
there's no comparison between
kierstarma following the rules in 2021
and boris johnson breaking the rules in
2020 no comparison whatsoever and i
understand why
the conservative party unable to defend
boris johnson wants to now start going
on the attack and smearing other people
to cause distraction but there is there
is genuinely no comparison between the
two
the two
and i i think
what we've got to do
is to
show could you go back to the point
about the politics that it's not enough
for labour for the government to lose
the next election we've got to earn
trust and win the next general election
and by the way trevor i don't think you
should apologize for um talking about
your personal pain because millions of
people up and down the country are
having the same conversation it's come
up on the doorstep time and time again
in recent days and i think that that
image we saw of the queen isolating the
reason why that image is so powerful is
two fronts
one it showed that people were following
the rules and if her majesty the queen
who is actually genuinely the only
person in the country who is legally
above the law thought it was important
to follow the rules and set an example
why did the prime minister think that
somehow he was above the rules
and and and what the queen has done as
she often does is epitomize a national
mood and a national moment and
she took that responsibility seriously
in the way the prime minister didn't so
i think people are furious and her and
actually one of the uh most powerful
interviews i heard this week was a
caller into a radio program
who
was in bits because he'd enforce the
rules at funerals and was now asking if
he'd done the right thing and felt
terribly guilty about it
and that's what the prime minister
either doesn't understand or doesn't
care about was that people were doing
the right thing we were all in it
together boris johnson and number 10
weren't and that's why he's unfit for
office
against that background and you know
i
we don't have to argue about what you
just said um
it's curious that you know labour is
asked is has said rhetorically prime
minister must resign
but why is there
no vote of confidence why are you
leaving this to tory back benches just
to sort out
well i think there are three routes to
the prime minister going um he could do
the right thing and resign but boris
johnson and doing the right thing rarely
appear in the same sentence he can be
removed by conservative mps
through a motion of no confidence
through the 1922 committee and i
understand more letters are coming in
but they're not there yet or he can be
removed by the electorate those are the
three routes to the prime minister going
and i think what conservative mps need
to weigh up very carefully is whether in
the end they are going to allow a toxic
radioactive prime minister to
contaminate their party because one of
the reasons i push back on the idea that
they're all the same is that when things
like this happen in politics sometimes
the voters do say you're all the same i
don't think we're all the same i don't
think most conservative mps were out
breaking the rules but voters will judge
them if they defend the indefensible if
they stand by the prime minister if
they're complicit by their silence and
that's why they should remove him
because otherwise the voters will remove
them at the next general election hang
on i don't really understand this i mean
one of the routes is a vote of no
confidence in parliament which you could
instigate we could not you do we could
bring forward a motion of no confidence
in the government we've been around the
blocks with this before that would
galvanize the conservative party that
would be the politics how do you know
how do you know that you that would be
the political you don't know that until
you try it
i i i just don't think that's true i
mean i know tory mp's well enough trevor
to know the way they behave they don't
want to bring down the conservative
government i imagine they are concluding
uh in their own
minds and judgment and in their own
consciences that boris johnson is unfit
for office the question now is whether
they have the courage to act well look
um
i don't want to seem overly cynical here
mr streeting but actually uh there is a
point of view that says that the people
who most benefit from having boris
johnson
deeply wounded damaged but still in
office is uh the labour party and that
actually for you having him clinging on
in number 10
uh is better for you as a party even if
getting him out you think would be
better for the country
all of this rhetoric is really just a
way of making sure he stays there no no
i'm not make no bones about it boris
johnson carrying on is great for the
labour party if i'm thinking about this
purely through the prison of party
politics my message to tory mps is keep
him on knock yourselves out literally
you'll be knocked out at the next
election but we're still in the middle
of a national crisis here and the prime
minister's actions and judgments matter
in fact it comes back to the point i
made about plan b measures
if a prime minister or health secretary
from the conservative party is coming
forward and saying we're going to remove
plan b measures i want to be absolutely
confident they're making that decision
in the national interest and not in the
party interest for party management
reasons i don't have total confidence
about that it's one of the reasons why
in the coming days i'll be talking to
leaders of the nhs and talking to
government scientists and other
scientists to get their independent
impartial view because i can't trust the
moment ministers are guided by one
principle and one principle alone which
is public health before party politics
so this is not good for the country i
think boris johnson ought to go in the
national interest i know we'll be stuck
with a conservative government for a bit
longer and i hope it is just a bit
longer and the responsibility ultimately
falls on us to show the voters that
we're not complacent we're not waiting
for government to fall into our laps we
don't think it's the case that because
the tories are in a mess that people
just flock to labour by default we want
to win people's trust i mean that's why
yesterday kierstama did a big speech
about the future of health and social
care he could have just banged on about
boris johnson for 20 minutes and
everyone would have loved it but he did
that speech to show the country that
labor has a plan labour has a vision for
the country labor is ready for
government indeed well he's made
speeches like that before and it doesn't
seem to be working because um this
morning's opinion poll which puts you
ten
points ahead as a party
has a rather interesting finding and let
me just quote what the director of
research is opinion says when we tested
possible successes to johnson while most
of the cabinet got negative ratings
nearly half of people say they think
rishi sunak would be a good prime
minister a figure that is higher than
both labour's vote share and kierstarm's
approval rating so actually
your vote lead is really more to do with
johnson's unpopularity than the uh the
the the idea that the voters have had a
come to jesus moment labor and
discovered that labour is is the what
they're looking for well we're
absolutely not complete complacent care
is not complacent whenever we get new
polls out showing a labour lead kiara is
the first person to say we're not
looking at this through rose tinted
glasses we've got work to do still to
win back trust but that's why in the new
year he did a big speech outlining his
vision for the country and the
principles that would underpin a labour
government followed up very quickly by
substantial speech about health and
social care you'll be hearing more about
this from kier and from the rest of the
shadow covenant over this year because
this is the year where we will be saying
to the country we've got a terrible
government the country deserves a better
alternative here is labour's alternative
and that's where we'll be in 2022. all
right one quick last question um labour
backbencher barry gardner received over
400 000 pounds from a source linked to
the chinese communist party for his
political work
will he and any other mp who benefited
from that kind of money be required to
return it by the labour party
i don't know that we can require him to
to return it i do think this is very
serious
i do think that we've got a real issue
here uh which extends beyond one labour
mp it's also about access to government
ministers that's why to be honest both
of our parties aren't treating this as a
party political knockabout it's being
taken very seriously by the leadership
of both parties we can't have a
situation where a foreign government
particularly one hostile to
britain's interests on a number of
levels is able to directly interfere in
our politics that's what we've got to
draw a line under and i hope that very
quickly we'll be having a full review of
what's happened the lessons that need to
be learned we also need to act very
quickly
the intelligence security committee made
a whole number of recommendations in
relation to the russia report many of
those haven't yet been implemented so i
think there's an urgency to act national
security's got to come first we're
streeting thank you very much for your
time this morning thank you